acaba de iniciar la audiencia de control
de acusación que es este una de las
actividades previas al inicio del
proceso en el juicio que se le sigue a
Alejandro Toledo que las autoridades
peruanas calculan debe comenzar entre
junio y agosto en esta audiencia El
jueves Richard Concepción carhuancho ha
dispuesto que la fiscalía confronte al
ex gobernante y le señale las pruebas
los documentos y los testimonios
implicados que señalan a Alejandro
Toledo de presuntamente haber recibido
35 millones de sobornos en la empresa
brasileña odebrecht y justamente el juez
Richard el fiscal José Domingo Pérez
será en el encargado de encarar a Toledo
y a su defensa los delitos que habría
cometido Como colusión agravada así como
lavado de activos por presuntamente
haber facilitado que odre G realice
obras en Perú a cambio de coimas Y esa
audiencia se ha iniciado con la
intervención del abogado de Toledo
letrado Roberto sub quien se ha quejado
contra las autoridades peruanas porque
ha manifestado que supuestamente el ex
gobernante habría sufrido un maltrato al
ser sometido a largas horas de
diligencia sin ingerir ningún tipo de
alimento